A common complaint among school voucher
and charter school advocates is that
media coverage of school choice research
is biased. Do they have a point? Two
colleagues and I examined this by
identifying five pairs of nearly
identical studies. Each pair measured the
same outcomes and used the same
methodology. The only difference in each
case was the results:
One study in each pair found a positive
result for school choice, the other a
negative one. We then examined major
media coverage, tallying national news
stories and editorials citing each study.
We found that news coverage played no
favorites: Coverage of positive and
negative studies was evenly balanced.
Editorial pages were another story,
however. They mentioned negative studies
twice as often as otherwise identical
positive ones, and research was much more
likely to get mentioned by editorials
than by news coverage. Given this
editorial slant, it's easy to see why
media coverage can feel tilted. But news
coverage played it straight in this case,
and that's a good thing.
Do you think media coverage of school choice is fair?
Let us know in your comments. Also, let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.